the media stuff is so shocking to me
because i you know i worked at cnn for
years and i posted a couple shows there
several shows there and then i you know
i was the main anchor in msnbc for four
years i got fired
but you know i i still have a really
good friend who will remain nameless who
works there just a wonderful person
really good guy and i have a couple of
friends at cnn so
not a ton too but uh but anyway but i
know that world really really well
and the biggest surprise for me in one
sentence is how ill liberal they are i
always imagine their liberal networks no
no i'm liberal
okay in the sense that like i believe in
the enlightenment and i i believe in the
bill of rights and i think we do have
rights um
they are not liberals they are defenders
of the powerful which is the much graver
sin like you can have silly politics i
get it i've had silly politics maybe i
do now people make mistakes
but defending the billionaire class
blaming everything on like working-class
white people who are like you know
by far
the most shafted people in america look
at the suicide rate look at the death
rate i mean it's like it's measurable
but everything's their fault
i just want to talk about the media
landscape in general because one of the
things that i'm realizing now that i'm
back on the grid is i spend so much of
the time on my show just cleaning up
lies
just aoc said this it's a lie cnn said
this it's alive kavanaugh everything
they said was a lie covington kids all
the stuff that you've covered obviously
and i'm just a little curious uh first
off like how bad you think really like
the cnn msnbc new york times wapo
machine is on one hand but on the other
hand just like a little insider stuff on
how you guys go about doing your show on
a daily basis because i know your
producers a little bit and obviously i
go on the show and i find that you do
the show in a way where it's like you're
almost doing like uh it almost feels
more like a book than a tv show where
it's like each day you're doing
something and then you sort of pick up
the next day and pick up the next day
and i'm trying to do something similar
here so that everything doesn't feel
like this disconnected lunacy that that
everyone else in i'm just wondering a
little bit about like the nuts and bolts
about how you guys decide to do what
you're going to do
well i'm a writer so that's that's how i
think you know in terms of chapters and
you know serials this is a story i'm
giving you one installment today another
tomorrow it's just how my brain works
um but it's a practical matter you know
i wake up not too early i hope and uh
with my wife and for dogs i try and sit
outside for a minute get my head
together and then i write out a memo
every morning for the whole staff
on what i think the lead ought to be who
we should book and we've got a whole
pipeline of some unbelievable people who
work on the show just really really
smart i mean really smart and um
one of the people i talk to a lot so you
know we've had if i can brag the same
staff for five years i think we've lost
one person two people it's pretty big
staff
um and they're just they're all in
they're so clever they're so creative
they're so interesting but one of our
our head tape guy is a guy called tom
fox a guy's
freaking genius
and he really is my window into cable
news like the poor guy is very smart but
he watches all skateboards
so he's constantly texting he drinks a
lot i'm guessing
what he drinks a lot i'm guessing i i
don't he seems pretty sober but i mean
maybe he's on pills i don't know
but i like you know
i sit there with my you know stupid
glasses on on my phone and i'm looking
up i i honestly can't believe that i
cannot believe they didn't say this
um so basically by like 11 30 in the
morning you know i've sketched out what
i think the show should be in my mind
it's always because again i was a
reporter and a magazine writer i think
in terms of the lead you know what's
my editor used to say to me when i was
kid get in the lead like but what's the
lead like how do you open it up you know
what's the what's the theme
and i try to as just a as an exercise
that i've always
um
you know that i learned as a kid and
i've always used sum it up in a sentence
you know what's it about you know our
first segment usually goes 20 25 minutes
what's it about one sentence it's not
about eight things it's about one thing
how would you summarize it and that's a
really
helpful organizing principle
for putting it together
and then you know right around five
o'clock i try and take a sauna every day
because i think it's really important
right now as scandinavian i'm true to my
people and uh i think about it in the
sauna then i go out i think about it
more and then i sit down around five
have a cup of coffee and i start writing
um the lead and that's basically it but
the media stuff is so shocking to me
because i you know i worked at cnn for
years and i posted a couple shows there
several shows there and then i you know
i was the main anchor in msnbc for four
years i got fired
but you know i i still have a really
good friend who will remain nameless who
works here just a wonderful person
really good guy and i have a couple of
friends at cnn so
not a ton too
but uh but anyway but i know that world
really really well
and the biggest surprise for me in one
sentence is how ill liberal they are i
always imagine they're liberal networks
no no i'm liberal okay in the sense that
like i believe in the enlightenment and
i i believe in the bill of rights and i
think we do have rights
um
they are not liberals they are defenders
of the powerful which is the much graver
sin like you can have silly politics i
get it i've had silly politics maybe i
do now people make mistakes
but defending the billionaire class
blaming everything on like working-class
white people who are like you know
by far
the most shafted people in america look
at the suicide rate look at the death
rate i mean it's like it's measurable
but everything's their fault
it's insane cnn ran a piece today saying
white supremacists are applauding the
taliban and it's like
okay uh you know i don't even know what
they're talking about who are these ways
but leaving that aside it's like what
are you really saying you're saying the
real problem with the withdrawal from
afghanistan was not terrible decisions
that the by administration made of the
pentagon made or that our entire foreign
policy establishment bipartisan made for
20 years now the real problem is some
guy in alabama who's got unauthorized
views it's like maybe you should stop
attacking these people because they are
the weakest people in our society and
you're doing it in order to defend like
the shittiest people in our society but
also the richest and the most powerful
you're the praetorian guard for the most
powerful people like how can you live
with yourself i mean that that is so
immoral
what do you think what do you think the
answer to that question is how do they
when when you have to cover some idiotic
thing that stelter said or cuomo
just these these clown people when you
have to cover it right or don lemon as
you call them like what how do you think
they live with themselves at this point
when they just lie again and again and
we have the internet to expose the lies
if this isn't 20 years ago when you were
on cnn yeah and we couldn't expose
things we can expose it now and they
still do it
well it's i guess i would ask myself
like i mean i lie
if i'm really cornered or something i
lie
i really try not to
i try never to lie on tv i tr i just
don't you know i don't like lying i
certainly do it you know out of weakness
or whatever
but to systematically lie like that
without
asking yourself like why am i doing this
so if if these people ask themselves why
am i doing this you say well because i
want to protect
the system because i really believe in
the system okay who's running the system
you're you're lying to defend jeff bezos
like you're treating
you're treating bill gates like some
sort of moral leader like are you
kidding like how dare you do that how
dare you use your power
to protect and guard the powerful
even as you
clamp you know put your boot on the neck
of the weakest piece some some catholic
school kid from kentucky it's like a
parody are you kidding he's a child
and you're using your power to
to crush him to wreck his life like that
that shocks me and i have to say there
have been many times in the 25 years
i've been in tv where i think
you know are we using this
like very substantial power that we have
to put pictures on the screen
to hurt
weak people and i have done that
inadvertently over the years because i
got carried away but i really try not to
and everyone who works on our show
is very aware of like the most
basic rule which is don't piss down
don't attack people beneath you if
you're gonna you know take a punch make
sure it's upward someone who's rich or
stronger more powerful in charge of more
things than you are punch up
like that's just like a life rule and
people who punch down are the are the
worst they should have no power
whatsoever in my opinion if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell